[Music]
this video sponsored by kog games the
new game Kurtz Belle is an anime style
action battle game from a third-person
perspective where players can battle it
out in both PvP and PvE mission based
battle modes with massive boss monsters
you can enjoy various 2v2 PvP modes
queued up by a smart automated
matchmaking system or you can embark on
a larger-than-life raid style quest
driven battle system against big bad
boss monsters make sure you check out
the link in the description for more
info
now said before a hero's only as great
as the challenges he can overcome now we
can't seem to get enough of the people
who stand in the way of our heroes and
their goals whether it's because we love
to hate them or because we can relate to
the villains mentality to some degree
it's very likely that we all like the
bad guy at NC bit more than the good so
today I have a list for you of the
greatest challenges that ever existed in
the anime ecosphere these are some of
the most overpowered villains in anime
and when they first showed up the
initial response was how is anyone ever
going to beat them
[Music]
starting off the list at number 10 it's
cars from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure cars
is the leader of the pillar man and the
creator of the stone mask the pillar men
are an ancient species that used to rule
over humans and who was seen as gods his
only weakness is the Sun so he made the
stone mask to overcome this weakness to
rule the day world his tribe objected
and tried to stop him but he slaughtered
them Kars is one of the most powerful
characters in JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
his light mode allows him to produce
blades from his limbs that can produce
blinding light his ultimate form allows
him to manipulate his body by having
access to the genetic code of all of
Earth's known life-forms cars ripple is
comparable to the intensity of the Sun
and can vaporize human flesh on contact
[Music]
next at number nine is zeref from Fairy
Tail now don't let this man's young and
innocent appearance fool you he's over
400 years old and is known as the
strongest and most evil wizard ever his
alias the black wizard is a reference to
the black magic curse that he carries
the black art will kill everyone around
zeref instantly if he holds any
affection for life but when he managed
to completely stop caring about all life
the black art became a weapon he could
control a will so other than black magic
he's also mastered living magic fire
magic telepathy enchantment and even
time and space magic not to mention that
he's also a conjurer that has summoned
countless powerful demons into the world
[Music]
eight it's all for one from my hero
academia all for one is the villain
above all villains the man without whom
all might wouldn't exist his presence
puts fear into your body and his power
allows him to take others quirks for
himself or to give them to other people
even though his age hasn't been
officially confirmed he should be almost
a century old at the point of the series
where we first meet him all for ones
abilities are endless but some of the
ones we know of a warping air-cannon
super-strength absorption multiplying
arms super regeneration and loads more
[Music]
at number 7 its Altai air from recreate
errs all tire AKA military uniform
princess is the main antagonist of
recreate errs she's the one responsible
for bringing the created into the real
world with her plan being to destroy
everything by crashing different worlds
against each other
al Saher has many standard abilities
such as super-strength magic flight
telekinesis but what makes her
overpowered is the ability to remove an
altar parts of others creation stories
she could revise a story and change
siliceous sword rebellion into a flower
she could make certain characteristics
of a creation disappear she could and
plot twist to a creation story and among
other things she could overtake another
creations consciousness and become them
[Music]
number 6 we have big mom from one piece
Charlotte Lin Lin the captain of the big
mom pirates is the only female Yong Cove
Charlotte was very powerful way before
being nicknamed big mom as a
five-year-old kid she was massive
towering above all other children her
size made others compared her to Giants
but in strength she was outmatched
during her rampage over being starved
she destroys a whole L bath village L
buff being the land of giants
none of the Giants could stop her and
she injured many of them fatally now as
an adult she's one of the Emperor's of
the sea one of the four most powerful
pirates in the world and as the only
female in the four we can only assume
she's the strongest woman in the world
through her strength she's managed to
create a very powerful crew with some of
the world's strongest pirates on her
side her devil fruit the sole soul fruit
allows her to manipulate freely with
Souls she can take them out transfer
them cut ones lifespan in half and do
many other manipulations
[Music]
next on the list at number five its
father from Full Metal Alchemist
father's the oldest of all homunculus
and the creator of all other modulus he
considers himself worthy of divine
status and demands the ownership of the
world he's thousands of years old and
was first introduced to humanity with
the ancient kingdom of Xerces where he
managed to manipulate the king and the
alchemists van hollen hime to sacrifice
the entire city that gave father the
power of all of those souls and become
immortal father's so powerful that his
creation the seven deadly sins are
virtually indestructible his alchemy is
without a match and he has the ability
to create a miniature Sun if he wants to
father was a being that rivals a God
which he literally tries to absorb some
tried to overtake God some tried to
defeat him but father's the only one who
ever tried to literally eat God
whatever misery cosa yeshua
a little scholarship moving on to number
four it's boots auto front Gintama boot
sort was born with an ability that
allowed him to absorb and contain a high
amount of Altana the planets lifeforce
granting him immortality and
regenerative abilities after a society
tried to kill him out of fear they
locked him up in a prison where he was
forgotten about for decades when his
door cell rotted away he escaped in
order to cope with the suffering and
torture he sustained but sorrow
developed multiple personalities some of
which to no one's surprise wanted to
kill everyone
buuut sorrow became a mass murderer but
was caught by the imperial government
but instead of executing him they
decided to make him an assassin he
formed naraku a secret assassination
group and led them for over 500 years
thanks to his overwhelming powers and
500 years of experience has become a
master swordsman with no one to match
him he can be compared to a grim reaper
with the ability to slay entire
countries what she'll cut out will you
at number 3 its eysan from Bleach sosuke
aizen was originally introduced to us as
the captain of the fifth division in the
goat 813 captain being one of the
highest positions one can strive for in
the soul society but aizen's ambitions
were even greater than that aiming to
become the God of all worlds Aizen is a
genius well versed in strategy and
tactics he has knowledge unknown to most
such as the existence of the oken the
key to soul king's palace and the method
to create it he's created several
hollows and arrancars all while avoiding
any suspicion from soul society he
experimented with the Hana fication of
Shinigami something no one has ever done
before he has a high proficiency in Kido
spells and is even able to use
high-level Kido spells without their
incantation Aizen has immense spiritual
powers even by a captain standard and
few if any one rival his strength in any
of the worlds
[Music]
coming sky Rocco
number two on the list is Madara
from Naruto Madara Uchiha is the
legendary leader of the Uchiha clan
during the ancient wars his strength was
forged in battle against his rival
hashirama senju the two of them were
considered the strongest ninjas to ever
live his knowledge and strength allowed
him to play a central role in major
parts of history his powers are so great
not even the 5 gar gaze could defeat him
even after joining their strength his
eyes strength and experience allow him
to perform complicated techniques with a
single hand seal during the great ninja
war he would enter the sage mode via
absorbed hashirama cells despite having
no prior training in senjutsu his
Sharingan technique allowed him to gain
the highest level of Sharingan eternal
mangekyo sharingan and create a
full-body Susanoo it would take the
combined force of some of the greatest
ninjas in the world to even attempt to
stop him
[Music]
Oh
and finally at number one it's Miriam
from Hunter hunter Miriam was the most
powerful offspring of the Chimera ant
queen simply known as King for the
majority of his life the Queen gave
birth to him to be the perfect offspring
and it was reflected in his attitude of
holding himself superior to all other
forms of life he had no empathy for his
own race killing and cannibalizing at
the first sign of impudence and he saw
humans only as a source of food Miriam
goes through character development
unlike any other on this list it's this
intellectual and physical fight he has
with the world's strongest hunter
chairman Attero that played pivotal
points in his life and development of
all the characters on this list Miriam
is my personal favorite he stays as the
most powerful character in the series
long after his introduction you know who
can defeat these guys I have got a whole
list full of them so if you haven't seen
my most overpowered main characters
video do make sure you check it out okay
be sure to leave a comment on who's your
favorite overpowered antagonist and
leave a suggestion for a video you'd
like to see on this very channel if you
want to help me out then please leave a
like because that really helps with the
YouTube algorithm I've pumped up the
production pace of these videos and I've
got some great ones coming up soon so
make sure you subscribe to find out
first when I upload them don't forget to
check out our sponsors new game Kurt's
belt the link is in the description I'll
see you guys next time on Vinnie tube
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]